168 years before game of thrones
the targaryens were at their peak
investors there were many targaryens and
even more dragons
from the perspective of every house in
the seven kingdoms major or minor
as well as from the perspective of
commoners and even from the perspective
of targaryens themselves
the targaryen rules seem to be so
powerful
that even 1 000 years from then on they
would still rule the continent
but then the dance of the dragons
happened it was a targaryen civil war
that saw the end of many targaryens and
most of their dragons
it nearly destroyed their entire house
this is one of the most exciting
and most epic events that ever happened
in the history of this world
and it's exactly the event that house of
the dragon will follow
therefore it should not come as a
surprise that many main characters of
the show are going to be the dragon lord
ancestors of danny targaryen and jon
snow
the series is based on george r martin's
book fire and blood
which covers the entire targaryen
history in westeros
starting from aegon targaryen and his
conquest and going to the dance of the
dragons
while fire and blood part 2 will also
cover the blackfyre rebellions
and will end with robert's rebellion the
prequel series house of the dragon finds
the targaryen dynasty at the absolute
apex of its power
with around 20 dragons flying over
king's landing and dragonstone
most empires surreal and imagined
crumble from such heights
in the case of the targaryens their slow
fall begins
almost 192 years before the events of
game of thrones
when king viserys targaryen breaks with
a century of tradition
by naming his daughter rhaenyra heir to
the iron throne
but when viserys later fathers a son the
court is shocked that rhaenyra retains
her status as his heir
and seeds of division so friction across
the realm so basically the show starts
with king viserys the first targaryen
sitting on the iron throne with rhaenyra
his oldest child being his heir
instead of his son aegon much to this
pleasure of aegon's mother queen ellis
and hightower
through a series of flashbacks we'll
learn about why king viserys chose to
keep rainer as his designated
heir even when he got a son we'll also
learn about the tension in the king's
landing court between raniere's faction
and
alice sats faction or in other words
between the blacks and the greens
rhaenyra's faction obviously supports
rhaenyra while alice's faction supports
aegon as the future ruler of westeros
king viserys the first targaryen had
three children by his first queen and
marina
but only one princess rhaenyras arrived
to adulthood
lacking a son to succeed him viserys
began to train rhaenyra to be
there young rhaenyra was included in
discussions of the affairs of the state
and was allowed to participate in
meetings of the small council
many of the nobles took note and
rhaenyra soon acquired a huge number of
supporters
after the passing of queen emma the
series named rhonera is there
and hundreds of lords and landon knights
paid obeisance to her
the king later remarried to ellison
hightower
and had four more children aegon helina
amend and deheron
a great tourney was held at king's
landing on the fifth anniversary of
zerus's marriage to allison during the
opening feast queen ellison wore a green
gown
while princess rhaenyra dressed in the
red and black of house targaryen
note was taken and thereafter he became
the custom to refer to greens and blacks
when talking of the queen's party
and the party of the princess
respectively well many expected that the
king would change the succession order
and the hightowers tried to persuade him
to do so many times
viserys only strengthened rhaenyra's
place in the succession
by marrying her to sterling or valerian
who himself had targaryen blood
through his mother princess rhaenys it's
not a big spoiler as his character is
not
that important but in season 1 lenore
will be executed
but i won't tell you by who although you
will probably figure it out
and after rainer's husband gets executed
rhaenyra will marry her uncle
prince daemon targaryen younger brother
to viserys
this only strengthens her position even
more as daemon himself has a lot of
supporters
and is arguably the best warrior
commander and general of this time
in season one it will also be
established that alisands and rhaenyra's
children have
hatred towards each other which will
lead to many horrible events by the time
the war breaks out
speaking of the war breaking out things
start to escalate towards the end of
season
one king viserys dies queen ellis and
hightower conceals viserys's death from
the public
and instead has sir kristen cole lord
commander of the king's guard
summon the small council to alison's
apartments in mangrove saltfest
grand maester orwell here predicts a war
believing that rhaenyra would never be
willing to give up her birthright
and had dragons at her disposal when
lyman declares that he was not willing
to listen to people plotting to steal
rhaenyra's crown
and attempts to leave sir kristen kills
him this makes
lymon the first casualty of the dance of
the dragons
after lyman's death the green council
made their plans
wowing their loyalty to their new king
and arresting all those in king's
landing who could be loyal to rhaenyra
to all those who might be loyal to aegon
ravens are sent
prince aymond hagon's brother is sent to
storm's end
to betroth himself to one of lord boris
baratheon's daughters
so how's baratheon might fight for aegon
ii
meanwhile rhaenyra remains on
dragonstone unaware of what happened
instead of coming to king's landing to
claim the trout
christian who once served rhaenyra
convinced viserys's son prince sake on
the elder
to claim the rule of the seven kingdoms
as his father lay dead
for this he became known as christian
the kingmaker
viserys had decreed his heir to be
rhaenyra targaryen princess of
dragonstone
the daughter from his first wifey marin
the green said the red keeps support egg
on the elder
the eldest son of his second wife alison
however
and kristen takes into custody and he
blacks remaining at court
alice sent forbid septons and silent
sisters from treating viserys's body
a week after viserys death his passing
is finally publicly revealed
with the greens accounting the ascension
of aegon ii targaryen
the silent sisters then prepared the
late king's body for the traditional
burning of a targaryen
aegon's coronation is hastily prepared
the dragon pit is chosen as the site for
its towering bronze doors
strong growth and thick walls making it
easily defensible
sir kristen cole crowned saigon while
alice sent hightower crowned saigon's
sister wife hailing
however the night before the first
defection had taken place
sir stephen darkling of the kingsguard
had left the city
with amongst other things the crown worn
by kings
jahir is the first and wizard is the
first and is taking it to the rightful
queen rhaenyra
at dragonstone rhaenyra finds out that
her father died
and aegon staged a coup and was crowned
king in king's landing
furious rhaenyra quickly made her own
council at dragonstone
the black council the participants are
amongst others
her uncle husband daemon her three
eldest sons jacarius lucerus and joffrey
lord corley salarian and his wife
princess rhaenys
rhaenyra is crowned queen using the
crown her father
and great grandfather had worn thanks to
sir steph and darklin
who had the ride from king's landing
prince damon places the crown on
rhaenyra's head himself
and is named the protector of the realm
and jacaryus is officially named the
prince of dragonstone
and there to the iron throne during the
council it's result that while rhaenyra
remains at dragonstone to regain her
health
prince daemon and characters would
travel to the riverlands to make harry
hall their base and railing point for
those loyal to rhaenyra
house valerian would close off the
gallet blocking all shipping from
blackwater bay
princess rainies is convinced that
storm's end would declare for rhaenyra
since lord bormann baratheon the
deceased father of lord boris and
renus's uncle
had always been a supporter of rhaenys
prince damon is also convinced that lady
jane aryn
the maiden of the vale would bring her
support to their side as rhaenyra's
mother was
irene herself although they believe the
north to be too remote to play
an important part in the war messages
are to be sent
to those lords nevertheless with the
eldest jacarius visiting the arranged of
the eerie
the man the release of white harbor and
the starks of winterfell
rhaenyra's second son lucerus travels to
storm's end
rhaenyra proclaims king aegon and his
mother queen alicent as well as their
supporters
traitors and the enemy of house
targaryen back at king's landing at this
point already a king
aegon proclaims rhaenyra traitor and the
enemy of house targaryen
and thus the targaryen civil war starts
dragons will dance
swords will clash monarchs will rise and
fall
and season 1 will end leaving you to
impatiently wait for season 2 to see
what happens next
basically the house of the dragon is
focused on the war of succession between
aegon ii
and his half-sister rhaenyra over their
father viserys the first round
the war that will be fought from 129 ac
to 131ac
it will see the deaths of monarchs the
deaths of targaryens and their dragons
as well as major battles across the
seven kingdoms with the starks and the
valyrians fighting the hardest on
rhaenyra's side
and the lannisters and baratheons
fighting the hardest on aegon's side
all of this and more you will see in
2022 on hbo
thank you so much for watching if you
enjoyed this video please give it a big
thumbs up and i hope to see you in the
next one
peace